and now that Phil Coulson is no longer
the director are you gonna be in the
field more more action yeah I think once
again he's a guy whose first name is
agent and whether he likes it or not he
is back in the field and I think some
part of him deep down feels comfortable
there and is happy to be there and he
seems to be back working in the field
with a new partner agent McKenzie and I
think that's exciting for him i figured
i'd make a good team the problem of the
human still be around yeah that's not
going anywhere that's just a
proliferation and you know it's in the
one hand people you might say it's a
problem but it might be something kind
of exciting there are good in humans as
well but it's certainly something on our
show that will be impacted by the sakova
Accords and those who wanted me want to
register people who are different now
with a revelation of Robby ray is Ghost
Rider and we sought out the car and I
saw you tease Lola on your Instagram so
are we can see Lola back or he's
possibly car chase between the two of
you I don't know that's a really good
idea we were you know I was on the set
and there was Lola temporarily uncovered
by some of the crew guys so I just
thought it was a beautiful picture I
don't know what's gonna happen yet I
imagine if he's got that cool car I
should probably get my own cool car out
all right so you just got your hair done
how do you feel about that I cry every
time I get something to my hair done cuz
like I was such a long hair person and
then just keeps getting darker and
darker and shorter short I'm like no my
security blanket but it's empowering
it's cool it I don't love it as Chloe
but for Daisy it's going to be super
super cool for the sea
now you're kind of headed a new
direction because i believe the show's
picking up right where the six months
jump forward and so so you're on your
own you're going rogue you're robbing
banks she I think you will see that you
know the bank robbing and all that stuff
is not exactly what it seems um but
she's mourning in her own way and you
know she lost people who are really
close to her and I feel like she kind of
is trying to make up for it in some way
or or that and make herself pay for what
she's done even though and not if it was
really her fault and so she's kind of
morning by pushing everyone she cares
about a way and probably causing more
problems so I'm getting really emo now
speaking of emo is was that outfit at
the end is that was that a disguise errs
at kind of daisies you look what we
talked about often on the show is that
her look is always changing so it's
she's always heard she's a chameleon and
that's her thing so there's never really
gonna be a set look and that's actually
fun because you see different versions
of cosplay like all the time like sees
one days a year goth Daisy ur gauntlet
Daisy or like sky you know so that's
really cool that there's so many
different versions of this character
she's always changing so there will be
different variations but I think we went
we're going towards a more like a darker
look not necessarily gone but definitely
just edgier how do you think fits what
we see if it's you know if it's we'll
find out about the LMD right away I
don't know if we'll be right away I mean
I think that I mean there's no guarantee
d well but you know I think I would
assume you know with Radcliffe coming
back and we've seen the LMDS that it
would be you know something that fits
becomes involved with you know that says
kind of feel do you think you'd approve
that's a good question lies I think he'd
be very intrigued by of course he was it
depends in what capacity they'll be
using before I mean I think the LMDS
from the comics as far as i know are
there to kind of protect and defend so i
suppose in that respect why you know why
would he not approve but yeah depending
on what way they're utilized I think
he'd be fascinated with the engineering
but whatever they made a ward that would
be set
you